To see if it's a tree, the first thing we need to do is to see if the graph is connected.
Looking through the 8 graphs, you can see that the fourth graph is not connected.
Recoloring the edges, we can see that these three nodes are not connected to these three nodes.
So, this one can't be a tree. All the other graphs are connected.
The next thing we need to look for are cycles.
The second graph is a ring, and it's obviously a cycle.
In the seventh graph, there's a cycle between these four nodes connected by the edges in pink.
So, that can't be a tree. That leaves these other fives graphs, all of which are trees.
Now, some of these--like this one--it's kind of obvious that it looks like a tree.
But the eighth graph doesn't really look like a tree. Why do we call it a tree graph?
What we can do is number and rearrange the nodes to make it look like a tree.
There are seven nodes in this graph, and I've numbered them 0 through 6.
Let's start rearranging this. Let's start with node 6.
Now, node 6 is connected to node 2, so we'll draw that connection.
Node 6 is also connected to node 1, so there's that edge.
We can see that node 2 is connected to node 4 and node 5,
and so we can draw in those nodes and the edges.
Then node 1 is connected to node 0 and node 3.
Here are those nodes and edges drawn in.
We can see that we can transform this graph, which doesn't look like a tree at all,
into something that looks a little bit more like a tree. It branches out.
Hopefully, that gives you some idea of why we call these tree graphs.